a seemingly endless queue of migrants
crossing the Rio Grande from Mexico into
the United States
they're part of a recent surge in
migrant Crossings in places like the
Eagle Pass Gateway One of the busiest
border crossings between the two
countries
many of them say they're fleeing
worsening political and economic
conditions in their home countries
the situation in my country is
suffocating
in Mexico the recent wave of migrants
appears overwhelming earlier this week
Mexico's national Railway service
ferromex announced a temporary
suspension of operations after several
deaths and injuries were reported
involving migrants falling from train
cars
freight trains are one of the most
popular methods used by migrants as they
make their way to the United States
collectively these rail cars are known
as La Bestia or the Beast
we've been walking for nine to ten days
walking is awful because in my group
which came here walking we go see our
face injured and with such a long way to
go until we reach the Border I don't
think we can even make it by walking
the crisis appears just as dire along
Mexico's Southern border with Guatemala
on Monday a group of migrants most of
them from countries like Haiti Cuba
Honduras and Venezuela forced their way
into a refugee station
absolutely uninformed they don't display
any sign anything that informs the
people I think they should find a
solution to this
facing a sharp influx of migrants from
Latin America and the Caribbean
immigration policy experts in Mexico are
calling on the government to establish
more processing centers for migrants to
prevent the current crisis from
worsening Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera